I put my heart into this film and so you
want it to be you might be a story to
reach other people and touch other
people's cards and so if I can do that
then I've done my job
I'm chanting Godfrey peoples I'm the
writer director of Miss June teen and
this is my fresh first I think miss
Juneteenth has always meant so much to
me because I've been living with
Juneteenth my whole life
Juneteenth is a commemoration of the
fact that the slaves in Texas didn't
find out they were free till two and a
half years after everyone else it's
something that I attend every year with
my family and in the centerpiece of the
Juneteenth commemoration is the Miss
Juneteenth pageant we call it a beauty
pageant but it's far more holistic than
that you know they they have their
talents they have their essay they go
through a program to develop them as
young women living in the world and what
I always remember about it was seeing
young hopeful african-american women on
stage and all that beauty with all their
talent and intelligence and for me as a
young african-american girl it meant so
much to me because it inspired
confidence and hope within me this
wasn't a difficulty but this was
definitely a challenge but I was also a
new mother myself my daughter turned one
on set coincidentally so I was juggling
being a mom and telling a story about a
mom as well which in a sense it was a
challenge but it also gave me a new
perspective on telling the story before
I had a very tough love version of
turquoise on paper but what I discovered
after having my daughter was that I
needed to find a way to bring the joy of
the love between a mother and daughter
to the film as well
see several reactions that I feel like
ok this is why I made the film and it's
been from people who say that they can
see themselves that they felt connected
to the mother and daughters journey that
they remembered their own mother or
their own daughter and they felt the
intimacy of that connection and that was
important to me because no matter what I
put my heart into this film and so you
want it to be you want for your story to
reach other people and touch other
people's hearts and so if I can do that
then I've done my job
Fanny pay you have to trust your
instincts no matter what production
designer
Olivia people's she's a brilliant actor
and definitely can say so much with just
the look she is so hard-working and was
constantly challenging herself on set if
you haven't seen this film it's a
must-see in my opinion it's definitely
in my top but it's Julie Dash's
daughters of the dust
you